there is a chilling dystopian proposal
from Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
wherein bloggers who write about
DeSantis or Florida legislators would
have to register with the state you've
got a Blog
you write about desanctus sometimes well
we need to put you on a list and the
ACLU is already saying this is
unconstitutional Newt Gingrich is even
saying that this is a bad idea so let's
discuss NBC news reports Florida bill
would require bloggers who write about
the governor and legislators to register
with the state the bill proposed by
Republican state senator Jason Brodeur
would also require bloggers who write
about State officials to disclose who is
paying them and how much interesting
the bill is called information
dissemination
if a blogger posts to a Blog about an
elected State officer and receives or
will receive compensation for that post
the Blogger must register with the
appropriate office within five days of
the post what it defines elected State
officer as the governor lieutenant
governor cabinet officer or any member
of the legislature if you fail to
register you will get a fine of 25
dollars a day
the penalty would be capped at twenty
five hundred dollars per post the bill
says the bloggers reports to the state
must include the individual or entity
that compensated the Blogger for the
blog post and the amount of compensation
received from the individual or entity
of course this could very quickly be
expanded to include independent
journalists YouTubers and others the
bill defines a Blog quote as a website
or web page that hosts any blogger and
is frequently updated with opinion
commentary or business content but it
says the term does not include the
website of a newspaper or similar
publication desantis's office said it
was reviewing the bill as usual the
governor will consider the merits of a
final bill uh if and when it passes the
legislature this is really scary stuff
many of these posts also or many of
these blogs are funded by advertising
and it's not that someone says hey I'll
pay you 500 bucks to write the post it's
you write the post and then it starts
generating ad Revenue some amount of AD
Revenue the other question is about
platforms like sub stack sub stack
allows bloggers to be compensated
directly By Their audience often they
are paid some number of dollars a month
so the compensation proposed sort of
depends on the average number of paid
subscribers you have over the period
that that post is live very difficult
aside from the chilling effect that it
has generally
very difficult sometimes to determine
the exact dollar amounts associated with
this the ACLU reports Business Insider
believes that this is a violation of the
First Amendment if passed writes
Business Insider SB 1316 would require
all bloggers writing about the scientist
to register with the state two
organizations told Insider this is a
violation of the First Amendment the
bill is Un-American to its core a
representative for aclu's Florida
Chapter said this is a clear violation
of the First Amendment because it
strongly discourages bloggers from
speaking on politics one of the most
critical types of speech for maintaining
a democracy says the ACLU rep the ACLU
rep added that the First Amendment quote
protects our right to learn and read
free from Viewpoint based censorship the
U.S Constitution demands we transcend
such callous political agendas and
instead promote the value of freedom of
expression well there's no doubt that
this is not a bill
that promotes speech you can make the
case it won't limit it it only enforces
disclosure and registration but of
course in practice it absolutely will
have that dampening effect on those who
would like to write about Rhonda santis
and the state legislature uh Newt
Gingrich actually tweeted about this and
on this particular Point Newt Gingrich
is correct former Speaker of the House
Newt Gingrich tweeting quote the idea
that bloggers criticizing a politician
should register with the government is
insane it is an embarrassment that it is
a Republican state legislator in Florida
who introduced the bill to that effect
he should withdraw it immediately now
the irony there it's kind of a sad irony
is that while Newt Gingrich is
absolutely correct Newt Gingrich is also
partially responsible for creating the
world in which something like this is
something Republicans are even willing
to do now I'm not blaming him for the
bill but you can't ignore the pivotal
the the inflection point that happened
in the United States with the Republican
Party
when Newt Gingrich became the Speaker of
the House in 1994 and I've said more
about that previously on the show if
it's interesting to you uh check out my
interview with Noam Chomsky where we
discuss it let's hope it fails but if it
passes I'm wondering might this Force
the last true liberal Dave Rubin out of
the state of Florida something to think
about we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this
one of our sponsors today is fume fume
is on a mission to accelerate Humanity's
breakup from the bad habits that consume
far too many of us including ones that
harm our health fume is a natural
diffusive device that uses plants and
Behavioral Science to trade out your
negative habit for a positive one fume
is not a vape it's a non-electronic
device designed to transform your
negative habits instead of PODS filled
with potentially harmful chemicals like
a vape fume uses cores infused with
plants like peppermint and cinnamon for
delicious natural flavors fumes new
version 2 model is Snappy and tactile
with an adjustable airflow dial and a
magnetic end cap that's fun to fidget
with it's fume's goal to make switching
easy or even enjoyable they have
thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work how head to
trifum.com and use the code Pacman to
get 10 off today when you get the
journey pack which comes with three
unique flavors and the new version to
fume the link is down below